wir haben eine fünfköpfige Familie
beispielsweise die nicht arbeitet die in
diesem Jahr gut 37 38.000 Euro vom
Steuerzahler bereits bekommt der Grund
für die Armut der Kinder liegt dort in
der fehlenden Arbeit für die Eltern
vielleicht in fehlenden
Sprachkenntnissen auch der Eltern
begründet und deshalb sage ich hier um
die Situation der Kinder und Jugendliche
zu verbessern geht's nicht um einen
höheren sozialtransfer denn da ist schon
viel Geld im Spiel und wir müssen jetzt
etwas tun dass die Eltern integriert
werden dass sie in den Arbeitsmarkt
kommen und auf der anderen Seite dass
wir bei den Kindern und Jugendlichen die
Kita die Schule verbessern und dafür
sorgen dass kein Kind auf einen
Schulausflug verzichten muss weil das
Geld fehlt
[Musik]